we mentioned earlier that we're talking
about that gain of function this is a
little going back to what we're talking
about earlier that
you'd said in that story that the u.s
made it illegal to do gain of function
research
it was temporarily outlawed oh so it's
legal again no i think they shut it down
recently
and but so then they were paying a
company to fund it in china instead
no the money was a grant was given to
ecohealth and then ecohealth gave the
money to women
so it's like we didn't no not our
businesses where else are they doing
gain of function research that we're
paying
for everywhere but we're not paying for
we're paying someone else to pay for it
for us with our money
right as if you know as if uh
you know the other countries in the
world can't also pay for this yeah i
mean imagine how much of this stuff is
going on at all times right now
in any number of labs around the world
probably a lot
it's probably creepy okay i'm sure it's
a lot worse than we realized though
you know you have this this one lab in
wuhan we're doing this research imagine
what the us government has under under
lock
area if you want yeah if they're going
to be if they're going to be finding
funding to different labs in other
countries
imagine what they do when they actually
have their hands on the project you know
what i mean
when i heard about the story immediately
i thought maybe this is like a
cia black site type of thing yeah where
they say you know what
the really sketchy stuff we're going to
put it abroad
yeah we'll pay we'll underwrite it that
makes sense we'll put it abroad the
really sketchy stuff
but it's exactly the opposite you know
when you're dealing with sensitive
things like this it's not like you know
it's not like a cia black site in egypt
where you know a jihadi guy is getting
his
you know his mouth chopped off
something's happening sure yeah
something's happening
but like there's limited fallout from
that compared to
a wuhan virus play uh play dangerous
games man
with dangerous prizes yeah yeah yeah hey
david can we talk about your book for a
minute
sure a minute i'll hold it up yeah this
is so this is about
qatar you said that there was a shadow
what's it called exactly it's qatar
qatar's shadow war the islamist emirate
and its information operations in the
united states so the first thing
i thought was this is an american shadow
war in qatar but you were saying there's
actually
how do you say it qataris what's the
what's the word
qatari this is a qatari shadow war
basically being waged
upon the united states well in the in
the united states
for their let's say in the uh
media and government of the united
states
for uh you know for qatar's advantage
and for the advantage of
islamism um it's um i mean
real you know kind of really short story
is qatar is the state sponsor of the
muslim brotherhood
oh wow and they run al jazeera plus they
run al jazeera
ultra woke network with billions of
views on facebook
and they run a lot of other stuff too i
mean they run you know
brookings oldest and biggest think tank
in the world
oh yeah they're ron brookings i mean to
the extent that run
it's a very creatively you know
described so they will go there will be
big donors into brookings the us
but then they have a franchise so they
have
they have brookings doha which is
uh you know owned by the royal family of
qatar that's in qatar
and you know that's a black box of
funding i mean they don't have to tell
us what
you know how much money comes in there
so they use that um
that brand as as legitimacy
so what are they what are they doing
what are they doing to us so i mean
basically they're um they're doing a
couple things
i argue that the arab spring
that happened in let's say late 2010 up
until 2011
was a project of the qataris through al
jazeera and the brotherhood to
destabilize the middle east
really al jazeera was
let's say the primary mover of a lot of
those protests
and not only that it was you know
between al jazeera and
brookings and all the other assets that
qatar had in the united states
it was able to convince journalists and
politicians
um and influencers of of other types
that you know these um
these governments in the middle east
that you know have supported us and
we've supported for all these years
uh we should not support you know
mubarak we should support you know the
revolution against
against him let's say in egypt and the
same thing in libya the libya war was a
total al jazeera qatari production i
mean hillary clinton really wanted that
yes what did she say though we came we
saw he died no
she said look at she was in front of the
senate and she went on and on about how
wonderful al jazeera coverage is
she said that her quote was that is real
news but was it because they were
they were supporting what she wanted um
yes so there was there was there was an
alignment there
what i believe she wanted there was
and what the whole obama crowd wanted
with libya was
they wanted to go in they wanted an
opportunity they saw what was
on al jazeera they saw the whole arab
world lining up against gaddafi
and they thought okay bush is gone
we want to start a new leaf we've made
the cairo speech we want to be good to
muslims
we want to do something to make the
muslim world like us
all they care about is getting rid of
gaddafi we're going to get rid of
gaddafi
and you know and um and we're going to
show them that stabilize the entire
northern african region destabilized
everything right
so so um so
all of the information for this came
from
al jazeera it came from sort of you know
qatari influence operators
but i wonder if they were just doing
what we want they're just doing what
what hillary clinton and and obama what
what they wanted in
north africa i mean especially when you
look at syria with the cutter turkey
pipeline
sure it would have been very beneficial
to cutter
but uh the u.s wanted to run a pipeline
up through syria and turkey into the
into
you know europe to offset the monopoly
coming from gazprom through ukraine
and uh cutter was like we'll make money
doing it i guess so let's just
say what they want say what america
wants america gives us stuff
we're gonna make money in the deal so
report what's good for them
yeah i i think it's um i think they're
dumber than that
all right honestly i mean they seem to
be successful yeah i
legit think that they're that they're
more ideological than that um
i mean it's a mix right it's a mix i
mean there's there's plenty of i mean
the libya thing is is a great example
because you've got sydney blumenthal
you know ready to make millions in there
there are a lot of shady shady stuff
as far as you know politicians or people
connected to politicians involved in
that
who are standing to make money off let's
say post war
libya but still regardless
there's a story that needs to be told in
public
for for anything to happen you know
you're talking about the syria thing
right people need a public narrative
people needed a public narrative
for libya too right regular americans
man uh it's just
it's it's it's maddening
when i try and have send out
conversations and they just don't know
don't care
and i'm like you're giving your money
and your vote to people
who hate you and are destroying the
planet
and they're like um now do you think
they always didn't care
yes that's that's that's effective
propagandizing you know and when you
look at these schools how they're doing
critical race theory
which is making a lot of these kids just
i mean what was that report that came
out like the u.s is failing
fourth graders are proficiency in signs
like 20 percent or some ridiculously low
number
because they don't they don't know
anything critical race theory
deconstruct deconstructivism whatever
you want to call it what they're doing
deconstruction
these kids are going to be dumb as a box
of rocks when they're older sure and
you're going to have a very very
loyal base of dumb people voting for
whatever you tell them to vote for
what's the point of running a country
what's the point of anything they're
doing
that's why i say they're extracting
value from the system and watching it
burn to the ground
because if your kids are going to be
dumb when you die you'll have dumb
people running the country ugh
worse than the dumb people running it
now so i think we're screwed with that
they go for the kids
they teach them things like two plus two
equals five you saw this stuff right on
twitter
why would you teach a kid two plus two
equals five so they're too
stupid to build to construct like a door
knob
oh i i got two pieces but how do i have
four doorknobs it's like right and on
one door on the same token you you've
got the the coddling of the american
mind was like
what what is it jonathan hate yeah yeah
who wrote that
that this whole thing you know all of
wokeness could be
understood to be a you know like how do
you make someone crazy
how do you make someone crazy how do you
make someone antisocial how do you make
someone
unable to relate to you know
to others and that's what they're doing
yeah and then they're creating a
a pitchfork mob that's what it is on
twitter there's people marching around
torches and pitchforks
looking for something because they're
angry and no rhyme or reason talk about
wearing masks and being afraid of each
that someone else is infected with a
virus making people anti-social
especially like young kids
that can't see faces you can't you're
forced to
cover yourself i mean but in
specifically in reference to educating
kids and educating them in ways that
make no sense
it's a wonderful is the big one
telling people the all altering the
history of the united states
now what you're gonna have is you're
gonna have some kids growing up learning
about ridiculous fake history
and other kids learning different
history and what's the what's the result
civil war yeah
no we have we have other options peace
means civil war is
i mean we we even have things that we
need to do before peaceful divorce
which is um which is a piece that i
wrote that i'm still preparing it's a
longer thing called autonomy
um which talks about the need for
let's say red america to create the
things that
frankly we don't have like uh
like financial institutions like social
media networks no
i like you know this this is this i
think this is a problem
the problem is that the the the the cult
infiltrated and took them over and then
conservatives are like well i'll go make
my
own it's like what you had one they took
it from you
well they may have taken some businesses
but like they didn't when people say
let's take back the culture
we never had the culture the culture was
always in the hands of
the federal reserve you know
organizations in the hands of the left
not the federal government
right that's the left uh but uh but no i
mean i think we need autonomy we need to
be making our own things
and i mean doing what you're doing it's
true
and uh here's what i think is going to
happen in 20 years
you're going to have a large amount half
population
are going to believe the united states
was founded in 1619
as a slave occupancy sure and then
you're going to have another half that
thinks the country was founded in 1776
as a classical liberal revolution of the
mind uh you know from
the colonists if you can't agree on what
your country is
then you can't function and we're
already the point
where you know i look at chuck schumer
and
in the january 6 commission these people
are
evil evil people it's funny because you
can look at objective reality
look at all of the videos i watched as
many videos from january 6
as as much as i could and i can tell you
that there were some people who were
very violent it was a riot
there were some people that were let in
by the police and the police agreed to
work with them
the police opened the door for many of
these people so how do i know
it's more likely to be true that's the
case i watched all of the videos
and i've had the reporters who were
there on the ground interviewed on this
show
and what the democrats are saying is
psycho
is psychotic it is deception it is lies
and the democratic voters buy it all up
without ever having looked at any of the
evidence
without ever having watched anything
they are mindless drones
and they're advocating for fascism and i
mean it
and i mean they've already put these
things in place i mean they've they've
they've already retooled there's a great
thread that i'll
i'll find i'll i'll sort of retweet it
about all the things that the
um that the let's say the national
security state
homeland security state has done to to
address
the the january 6th issue and
it's a revolution i mean they're
retooling everything from they're flying
black lives matter flags
at our embassies yeah that's it there is
a cold civil war it's been going on for
years i did not coin the phrase it was a
princeton professor who did he's a
democrat
and uh they they won now now it's the
resistance
most of the prominent uh we'll call them
belligerence in the traditional war
sense
have been purged from the culture war
sure alex jones milo
john f kennedy martin luther king i mean
this has been going on for a long time
dude this cold civil war this game
was co-opted in 1946 talking
specifically about what's going on right
you're talking about modern day i guess
a bunch of people have been banned and
removed from the fight outright
what's left are moderate types that are
like i reject
and that's it and we watch as the
embassies fly the flag of a cult
ideology
all right so so use the master you see
it i see it
what fascinates me now is are the people
who refuse to see it
and um i i just wrote a piece at the
american mind which is a
fantastic website about um
about sort of uh disengaging with these
people on politics
it's like if you have a fundamental
disagreement about
where you see these things going like if
you think that oh
you know we'll be able to snap back into
1980 or 19 or or
or two you know 2004 then you know what
maybe we don't talk about politics we'll
talk about music we're just not going to
go there
because this to me seems like like such
a no-brainer
i mean you had today i saw a guy who was
a kind of more um
nice guy but a kind of more uh
establishment conservative
writer he says you know what we can't
between crt on one hand
and let's say the the conservative
vision of education
of the founding on the other we have no
disagreement we have no
no agreement so we can't really have
public education anymore because it
doesn't have a unifying
you know ethos okay you got it
apply that to the rest of the country so
if conservatives
aren't actively trying to educate people
as to what's going on
then the left just wins it's over and
it's already hard enough with the
cultural institutions controlled by the
left and the constant stream of lies
the big lie from democrats about january
6. it's just one big lie
they don't want you to know that the
police opened the door they don't want
you to know that the doors were opened
by the cops
and they don't want you to watch the
video where that cue shaman walks up to
a cop and the cop says we're going to
work with you bp's one goes you got it
buddy
right and they don't tell you they don't
want you to know that a story came out
about the cue shaman stopping other
people from stealing from the break room
that he was saying we were going to have
a peaceful protest no they want him to
rot in solitary confinement
then you watch as police over the past
year
this is the problem with conservatives
police over the past year have been
arresting people
for minor violations on like wearing
masks there's no law
there was never a law when they said
when they shut these people's business
down
it was an edict a governor said i say it
it and it is so and the cop went you got
it and then started beating and
arresting random people
and the conservatives went back the blue
baby now once it started getting extreme
conservatives actually started backing
away from the police and pushing back
against them
but it's starting to come back to the
i'm seeing more and more conservatives
defending the cops again
and i'm like bro there's a lady in
florida i think
no no i'm sorry elizabeth city north
carolina she was driving one mile an
hour through a crowd of black lives
matter people who were banging on her
car and they're charging her with two
felony counts
the police did that okay your
institutions are controlled by the cult
the cops that are there right now are
the mindless drones
who would beat their own mother if their
boss told them to do it
you've got black lives matter flags
flying at the embassies you've got the
fbi
posting photos of people saying we're
going to get each and every one of these
guys
nothing happens to black lives matter
some things do do you know you know you
know how you
there's there's a really interesting
pattern that emerges the people who were
protesting for black lives matter and
rioting
the ones who the ones who were riding
and they got arrested do you know why
those particular individuals got
arrested
it's usually like they threw a brick at
a police department
they attacked a government building
specifically but when it comes to the
burning down of businesses
those people are free to go the the guy
who died in the pawn shop that burned
down to minneapolis
now we're not going to worry about that
at all oh but what was that
that bubba dude from nascar the garage
pulled up looked like a noose better
sending a dozen agents so this is
definitional anarcho tyranny yes exactly
it is what it is
you know these uh well maybe but no i
think we've just
i think that the cult is in control and
i think
conservatives sure i mean you can still
fight well right so you can say that you
know in in
in in many ways blm antifa
or agents of the state they are
absolutely agents of the state you know
and you know and uh and and if you
you know you fall outside that you know
you're on the right you're uh
you know that's exactly how it works
then i can i can sit here
and the hammer comes down but but a
mythology has to be created in order for
this thing to hold a mythology has to be
created about
our unique particular evil
which is what january 6th is right which
is the you know and
the commission is is this is the idea
what we're going to do now is we're
going to spend the next
x number of months to keep hammering
home every day
that um you know why these guys are
uniquely evil why this is the enemy that
you need to hate if you are a good
american
yep and republicans sided with democrats
on this one in the house and in the
senate
yeah look i mean it's shameful it's
shameful that
that i mean forget about trump right
this is not even about trump it's about
it's about sort of like baseline um
political warfare baseline awareness of
where we are in the movie you know this
is this is clearly what they're trying
to do they're trying to to uh
to create and to um
you know they're trying to to create
this this uh this phantom enemy
if if if this is a trilogy we just
wrapped up the the middle second movie
where it ends with a cliffhanger where
the heroes lose
no the two towers ended with them
smashing up eisenguard that was awesome
tree beard he's like we're going to war
and i'm like yeah
no it's more like uh um maybe star wars
where
you know an empire it's like khan's
frozen and like the empire's back and
they're like oh no
and it's like stay tuned to the next
movie so it's like you get the start of
the culture war
and it ends with the great victory of
donald trump and everyone's like yeah
then you get part two and it's donald
trump's presidency but then oh no
the empire strikes back and now we're
sitting there with the
mega death star with the force field on
it and uh we'll see we'll see
how it goes maybe someone will pick up
the emperor and throw him down a shaft
or or maybe we're
really early in the movie so that's what
that's what i was thinking
you know really or even in the or even
in the prequels
with the prequels yeah i mean who knows
i mean it's that bad right
uh and uh i don't know like you know in
the star wars prequels
they were there there were there was
turmoil but it was still like the
republic existed yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you